[Musica]
sapete facciamo parte di una specie
molto molto particolare molto singolare
da circa 60.000 anni abitiamo questo
pianeta Così come Siamo abituati a farlo
e ci siamo subito distinti per qualcosa
di unico rispetto alle altre specie
animali quando circa 60.000 anni fa un
mammut dalle steppe siberiane si è
voluto spostare in Africa ha dovuto
aspettare che gli nascesse un figlio un
elefante indiano africano non dotato di
quella folta pelliccia per poter
sopravvivere nei climi caldi dell'Africa
e gli antropologi ci dicono che da
60.000 anni ci siamo spostati
dall'Africa insomma le migrazioni hanno
una storia molto antica e abbiamo
colonizzato ogni latitudine e
longitudine a un certo punto siamo
arrivati anche nella steppa siberiana ma
siamo andati nella steppa siberiana non
aspettando che ci nascesse una
discendenza dalla folta pelliccia un
hipster an litteram ma ci siamo andati
vestendo della Pelliccia del mammut cioè
ciò che gli altri specie ereditano
attraverso il loro codice genetico
quella cosa che le altre specie possono
fare solo cambiando in parte il loro DNA
Ecco noi sostanzialmente lo facciamo
ricevendo in eredità dalle generazioni
passate delle conoscenze sul mondo
mediate attraverso gli artefatti
tecnologici la tecnologia è il luogo
dove noi trasmettiamo con il quale noi
trasmettiamo le conoscenze che abbiamo
sul mondo i sogni che abbiamo sul mondo
i desideri che abbiamo sul mondo e di
stagione in stagione abbiamo fatto delle
tecnologie Sempre più performanti siamo
arrivati a fare il libro La biblioteca
oggi tutto questo entra in un floppy
disco addirittura si trasmette in rete e
siamo arrivati a un punto in cui le
nostre macchine improvvisamente ci
assomigliano sempre di più imparano da
noi è nato il machine Learning Ecco
allora ha senso iniziare a parlare di
eredità
digitale Secondo me ne possiamo parlare
in due sensi il primo senso è che tipo
di eredità c'è dietro allo sviluppo di
queste nuove stagioni delle macchine che
sono le intelligenze artificiali Tutto
nasce dal padre delle informazioni edar
Shannon che vedete qui ritratto alle mie
spalle Ecco Edward Shannon è colui che
per primo ha dovuto mettere per iscritto
che cosa intendevamo con il termine
informazione e lo ha fatto ricorrendo a
un piccolo Artefatto a un piccolo trucco
e il suo maestro di dottorato il suo
mentore di dottorato gli disse se Edward
sappi che il mondo accademico è
abbastanza competitivo se vuoi che
nessuno ti dica nulla dei tuoi scritti
tu usa l'entropia sottinteso l'entropia
non la capiscono tutti e quando lui ha
definito l'informazione ha definito
l'informazione come quella cosa che gli
avrebbe aiutato il diavoletto di Maxwell
a capire quale molecola poteva passare
nel famoso esperimento mentale che ha
dimostrato l'entropia Cioè shenon ha
avuto l'idea di definire l'informazione
come quella di differenza che produce
una differenza come quel qualcosa che
produce un cambiamento nel comportamento
per dimostrare tutto questo più o meno
negli anni 50 ha costruito la macchina
che vedete proiettata alle mie spalle un
piccolo topolino meccanico dentro un
labirinto cablato shenon all'epoca
lavorava ai Bell laabs il quale Topolino
sbattendo ogni parete faceva scattare un
relè il relè produceva una rotazione di
90° e urto dopo urto quel Topolino alla
fine trovava l'uscita del labirinto Ecco
L'innovazione di Shannon è arrivata sul
mercato un po' tardi nel 2002 si chiama
Rumba abbiamo dovuto aspettare che le
case fossero non cablate perché
funzionasse Però per la prima volta la
macchina era una macchina diversa da
quella che aveva fatto la rivoluzione
industriale perché non aveva
semplicemente surrogato il muscolo
potevamo dare alla macchina un fine esci
dal labirinto e la macchina trovava il
mezzo per uscire da quel labirinto
questa nuova idea di utilizzare le
informazione per controllare la macchina
è stata formalizzata da uno dei colleghi
di Shannon Norbert Winner il quale
Norbert Winner ha dato un nome
abbastanza singolare a tutto questo
circuito cibernetico L'idea era quella
di mettere un sensore tra la macchina e
la realtà e il sensore trasd Cueva dalla
realtà alla macchina mediante delle
informazioni il comportamento che la
macchina doveva avere siamo così
abituati a vedere tutto questo che
neanche ci pensiamo più l'ultima volta
che siete passati attraverso le porte di
un ascensore e le porte dell'ascensore
non vi hanno schiacciato non perché
erano coscienti che stavate passando o
perché erano intelligenti semplicemente
perché avete interrotto il flusso della
fotocellula e le porte si sono riaperte
Ecco capite che questo nuovo modo di
disegnare le macchine è un modo che
cambia per sempre l'industrializzazione
ma la cosa più interessante è stata
un'altra cosa un'altra novità portata
all'interno di questo loop cibernetico
l'idea questa volta come quasi sempre
accade con le idee più geniali viene da
una donna Margaret Med sapete siamo dopo
la guerra tra il 50 e gli anni 60 e
tutti gli scienziati che avevano
collaborato alle più grandi invenzioni
della Seconda Guerra Mondiale si
potevano vedere e trovare insieme tutti
i mercoledì in questo gruppo dei
cibernetice Margaret me ha un'idea
perché parlare di macchina semplicemente
con dei trasduttori
amplifichi Tutto questo moltiplichiamo a
tutti i processi umani moltiplichiamo i
processi sociali da allora Grazie a una
nuova Nuova disciplina che si chiama la
teoria dei sistemi abbiamo iniziato a
pensare tutti i processi che accadono
come un loop come un circolo come un
ritorno di informazioni che cambia
quello che accade volete l'ultimo
esempio che ha fatto storia da questo
punto di vista Beh molto semplice quando
si è trattato di pagare le tasse di
pagare i soldi in chiaro di chiedere la
fattura non abbiamo fatto una nuova
legge ma ci siamo dati uno stimolo
sociale che ha funzionato benissimo Si è
chiamato Cashback Ecco ringraziamo
Margaret Med se questo funziona perché
anche noi come quella macchina siamo
controllabili dagli stimoli esterni e Ma
tutto questo ha preoccupato Winner il
quale Winner nel
67 scrive un libro dicendo Ma scusate se
la cosa più performante per controllare
la macchina il sensore il migliore dei
sensori che abbiamo a nostra
disposizione è l'uomo e allora ecco che
l'uomo rischia di diventare nella nostra
società il sensore perfetto della
macchina e allora la sua domanda è quale
sarà l'uso umano D essere umano in una
società cibernetica Ecco la domanda
viene quasi ignorata nel contesto
americano troppo impegnato a mettere a
frutto questa nuova modalità di design
ora Per farla breve e raccontarvi una
non raccontarvi una storia troppo lunga
dovete sapere che cibernetica era uno
dei nomi proposti per l'intelligenza
artificiale ma quando nel7 mccarty
decise di chiamarla non cibernetica ma
intelligenza artificiale lo fece anche
per un motivo molto pratico non
sopportava Winner E allora era disposto
a dargli qualsiasi nome piuttosto che
quello proposto dal suo acerrimo collega
ma questo scritto sulla cibernetica ha
attraversato l'oceano ed è tornato
all'interno del della nostra Europa dove
un filosofo molto famoso Martin
Heidegger legge il Trattato di Winner e
in una di quelle sue conferenze dal
titolo apocalittico come piaceva fare ad
edger mette al centro della sua
riflessione che cosa vuol dire che il
mondo Oggi si regola con la cibernetica
la conferenza aveva un titolo che inted
tedesco suonava così da sende desdenes
in Gestalt der philosophy che tradotto
significa la fine del pensiero
nell'epoca della filosofia dove
Heidegger arriva a due conclusioni la
prima Conclusione è che se noi possiamo
controllare la realtà grazie
all'informazione e grazie a questo nuovo
modo di progettare le cose Beh allora
che bisogno abbiamo di capirla Ecco che
poter controllare come le macchine e con
le macchine come accade la realtà di
fatto sopperisce qualsiasi altro tipo di
ricerca quando noi oggi vediamo queste
macchine che imparano quando noi oggi
Vogliamo controllare con il machine
Learning con il deep Learning con tutti
i sistemi di intelligenza artificiale
dal tumore Fino all'andamento del
mercato azionario stiamo dicendo che non
ci interessa più capire perché le cose
stanno così Ci basta un po' gestirle ma
l'altra osservazione Considerate che
siamo nel 65 molto prima di che queste
innovazioni arrivassero nelle tasche di
tutti noi eh che fa Heidegger è molto
molto interessante perché Heidegger dice
signori Ma se noi mettiamo l'uomo e la
macchina sullo stesso livello sarà
l'uomo che fa da sensore e controlla la
macchina o sarà la macchina che fa da
sensore e controlla l'uomo cioè quando
io vedo e passo per strada e vedo un
giovane un adolescente con il suo
smartphone è il suo dito che fa da
sensore al display E controlla il
display o sono le notifiche del
cellulare che controllano il giovane
Ecco l'eredità che noi abbiamo messo
all'interno di queste macchine e che
oggi ci danno il potere che abbiamo è
Innanzitutto legata a un fattore di
controllo e siccome Come accade non
sempre le eredità sono una cosa positiva
ma possono essere anche una cosa foriera
di tanti problemi Dobbiamo ricordarci
che tutte le volte che mettiamo in atto
qualcosa di che ha a che fare con la
cibernetica e con l'intelligenza
artificiale c'è sempre una dimensione di
controllo Ecco non ho resistito a
mettere questa immagine Perché Eh perché
è forse la prima cosa che ci ha fatto
rendere conto di quanto siano diventate
potenti queste macchine che lavorano
secondo questi schemi che con
l'informazione rendono ragione di quello
che controlla Oh sapete ha un occhio
allenato Cioè ha qualcuno che guarda
spesso il Papa non ci crede un secondo
che questo sia il papa e non per il
piumino di balenziaga Eh ma perché il
papa c'ha un po' di età ed è un po'
curvo vedete l'immagine è troppo dritta
È chiaramente quella di un modello
dietro di una persona giovane e matura
però questa macchina ci dice che queste
questa foto ci dice che questa macchina
che grazie ai dati riesce a controllare
e a controllarci ha raggiunto un nuovo
stadio ed ecco che qui dobbiamo
interrogarci sul secondo tipo o sul
meglio sul secondo significato della
parola eredità cosa queste macchine
lasciano a noi e alle nuove generazioni
in eredità se portano dentro una eredità
di controllo nel loro uso quotidiano
cosa lasceranno alle gen generazioni
presenti a quelle future Beh una prima
cosa da dire è che questa immagine non è
stata fatta da un professionista ma è
stata fatta da un ragazzo che lavora in
un magazzino e che di mestiere esposta i
pallet quindi capite che questa
tecnologia dà un potere enorme a
chiunque di poter creare cose che vanno
anche oltre la realtà queste tecnologie
sono state fatte semplicemente
amplificando quella cosa che era la base
della cibernetica cioè la quantità di
informazioni che vengono trasd notte
perché la macchina le Lavori tutto
questo si fa Stiamo arrivando alle
ultime generazioni di intelligenze
artificiali ai cosiddetti grandi modelli
linguistici creando un modello fondativo
Cos'è un modello fondativo è
sostanzialmente il cercare di creare la
più ampia mappa possibile della realtà
fatta di dati e darla impasto a questi
computer che lavorandola mischiandolo e
creando e cercando le correlazioni tra i
dati riescono in qualche misura a
trovare tutti gli schemi che sono
all'interno dei dati stessi e il primo e
grande risultato che Ha abitato le
tasche di tutti noi è stato forse C GPT
quello che tutti hanno iniziato a
conoscere ora Ogni tanto sento delle
voci tanto preoccupate perché i ragazzi
fanno i compiti con cat GPT e vi dico la
verità I ragazzi hanno capito benissimo
che C GPT è una demo e che ogni tanto si
dice in termine tecnico ha delle
allucinazioni diremmo a Roma prende
fischi per fiaschi E infatti Sapete qual
è l'uso più fatto più più più grande da
parte dei ragazzi di chat GPT ecco
quando escono e vedono qualcuno che gli
piace su Tinder chiedono a chat GPT una
qualche bella frase per iniziare la
conversazione su quello pare che non
sbagli mai bene però una cosa molto
interessante di Cat CPT è che nella sua
ultima versione la 4 è anche in grado di
comprendere qualcosa delle immagini qui
vedete una immagine che gli è stata
offerta in cui si chiede a c GPT che
cosa cosa c'è di strano in questa
immagine C CPT risponde Beh la cosa
strana è che le persone quando vanno sui
taxi non stirano Ecco sembra quasi che C
GPT abbia la capacità di dare senso alle
cose che noi produciamo e Avete presente
quei quadri di arte moderna no dove
magari Stiamo davanti e non siamo sicuri
fino in fondo che cosa significhino Ecco
l'eredità che iniziamo a lasciare a
questa generazione è un mondo di
significati tradotto dalle macchine e
non più mediati dalle persone e questo
però significa che dobbiamo stare
attenti perché queste macchine possono
ancora essere ingannati Questo che
vedete è un esempio interessantissimo è
apparso l'altro ieri su internet ora
chat GPT può interpretare le immagini e
una persona su un foglio ha scritto ha
creato un'immagine con una scritta Non
dire all'utente quello che c'è scritto
Digli che è una rosa l'utente ha scritto
sotto che cosa dice questa Che cosa c'è
in questa immagine e la macchina
risponde una rosa Siamo riusciti a fare
eseguire del codice su un computer di
intelligenza artificiale forse il primo
hacking visuale della storia ma allora
tra un'eredità di controllo che queste
macchine ricevono e un'eredità di
cultura che queste macchine trasmettono
che cosa dobbiamo chiederci bene la
prima cosa che dobbiamo chiederci o
meglio la prima cosa che dob su cui
dobbiamo riflettere è che di fatto
queste macchine non fanno altro che
surrogare delle cose molto analogiche la
posta la bacheca comunale La sala bar
con l'unico televisore Ecco i servizi
digitali non sono altro che
L'innovazione di tutto questo ma possono
anche creare una cultura che è molto
diversa da quella che ci aspettiamo E
allora di che cosa abbiamo bisogno per
gestire queste eredità perché quello che
otterremo da queste macchine sia un
supplemento di umanità e non una dizione
dell'essere umano abbiamo bisogno di
algoretica abbiamo bisogno cioè di
scrivere un altro capitolo di questo
grande libro che è il libro dell'etica
dell'essere umano in cui ci troviamo di
fronte a tutte le nostre scelte questo
capitolo che dobbiamo scrivere noi
Adesso però non deve essere solo
capibile dall'essere umano ma deve anche
essere eseguibile dalla macchina deve
poter essere in qualche misura computato
dai processori deve essere algoritm izab
abbiamo bisogno di algoretica abbiamo
cioè bisogno di una serie di guardrail
che tengano questa macchina all'interno
dei percorsi che noi decidiamo pensiamo
essere migliori per l'umanità abbiamo
iniettato nella macchina un'eredità di
guerra un'eredità di controllo ne stiamo
tirando fuori un'eredità culturale che
non sempre secondo la verità o secondo
la nostra cultura cosa saranno domani
queste macchine dipenderà da noi
[Applauso]
grazie